a mini a pretty Gerty that plays techno
music from Berlin a cake mold of the
German parliament or a cityscape clothes
hanger these are just some of the 20
most innovative designs for New Berlin
souvenirs they were chosen from 670
entries submitted to a city sponsored
competition this miniature Berlin wall
by Krista Fleckenstein stands and Falls
it was inspired by the East Side Gallery
a remaining section of the wall painted
by artists thinking about Berlin
souvenirs changes your perspective
because it has a Berlin designer you
have to assume another role I have to
play dumb and pretend I don't know
anything about it pretend I'm visiting
Berlin for the first time what do I see
here and most of all what do I want to
remember well understand you know the
designs for the new souvenirs are now on
display Berlin's government hopes the
competition will strengthen the local
designers ties to the city along with
the ever falling Berlin Wall the other
Prize winning entries include a
medallion that's an abstract map of
Berlin and wall hooks resembling East
Side Gallery graffiti fashion designer
Michele Michele ski oversaw the contest
of course Berlin has lots of souvenirs
but they're all the average trashy kind
you can get in any city unlik
declarative strata right now Berlin is
the most creative city in Europe if not
the world
dusty Bivona these are clear to even
start so why not have residents of this
creative city create souvenirs which in
turn
act as global ambassadors for the
creativity of this city naturally the
city's landmarks are also immortalized
as souvenirs
but the most popular ones include pieces
of the wall models of the East German
trolley car objects with Berlin's
heraldic animal the bear and ones
featuring the little men on the traffic
lights which originated in the former
East Germany
sales of these are rising around 20%
each year more tourists seems to
translate into more demand for souvenirs
the range is enormous the demands quite
modest it has to bring back all the
memories of you know being in that place
that's the main thing something light
not so heavy and some unique stuff in
Roli when I buy a souvenir
it's of something that's typical of the
city is not anything flashy but
something everybody is a real
purportedly authentic pieces of the
Berlin Wall have long been on sale but
the wall is also featured in the new
souvenir designs too there are pictures
of the East Side Gallery on rolls of
tape and reversible bags showing the
Brandenburg Gate before and after the
fall of the wall they're playful takes
on history they're roasting is venturing
to the humorous here's a trick to get a
more distanced perspective laughing at
something gives you a clearer view of it
we hope that our little piece of the
wall will make people smile and then
make them consider why they're doing so
fly in Moscow the designer and his
agency received one of the main prizes
for fall of the wall 2.0 they hope it
will later be mass-produced the fish
sticks
the important thing is that our creative
people the many designers who live here
took part and developed ideas for Berlin
and that we can make something of these
ideas compared to run-of-the-mill
souvenirs these new ones have at least
one distinct advantage they're
definitely made in Berlin